Good morning.
Isn't it?
Gene?
Helen Hunt?
Oh, my gosh! Billie, it's you!
I thought for a second,
and I almost said something...
that you were Helen Hunt.
You did say something.
Oh, I should have gotten this
whole chance encounter on video.
Can you go back and say
hashtag viral--
What are you doing here?
I go here. What's up?
They know me.
Like one time you go here,
or you--
No, I'm like a student.
Like, um-- oh here, like this.
"Books, books, books..."
Are you telling me that your dad
got you into the college...
that I'm teaching at?
Oh, like I need Kent Russell
to get me in.
Higher on the left!
Future Home of the--
Can't--
That could be a different dad.
If your dad thinks that I'm just
going to take care of you...
he is sorely mistaken.
Gosh, you are obsessed with
talking about my dad right now.
It's weird.
Okay, look--
Sh-sh-shhh-- there's a cake-beef
walking up.
Uh, hey, excuse me.
Do you guys know where the
philosophy building is?
Oh, I think the gym's that way.
No, I was asking about the
philosophy building.
I'm a mid-semester transfer.
Today's my first day.
Me, too! Absolutely!
Um, yeah... I'd love
to work out later.
Maybe.
Yeah. Oh, my gosh,
he's into me.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
What is the sorority rush?
College joke.
Okay, Gene, the last time
I saw you...
you tried to get me
the death penalty.
Billie, that was a courtroom gag
between old pals.
Wait, wait! Okay, okay, look.
The judge made me decide
between getting a job...
or going back to school.
So, now I'm trying the school...
way.
I thought I'd go to the one
you went to--
What are you saying?
'Cause I wanna hang out
with you more.
You're mumbling.
So... where should I enroll your
bag? College joke.
What are you doing?
What?
Give it to me.
That's my winter clothes!
That's my winter clothes.
Don't you make fun of me.
That's my--
Catch me, if you're my friend!
No!